what are some of the sins according to
Scientology
most of the sins from a Scientology
perspective are just doing or saying
anything that brings brings um disrepute
to Scientology itself right
um
remember they don't it's not like
Christianity where there's rules if you
break this rule you're not getting into
heaven yeah because scientologists and
think about things oh there's the drug
you can't do drugs right you can't do uh
drugs
uh and you can't take any psychotropic
medications and no medications almost at
all you're allowed to take medications
it's just um there's no rules expressly
uh prohibiting it it's just most
scientologists tend not to you can take
Advil but many scientologists won't
okay
um you just can't take anything
prescribed by a psychiatrist a
psychologist or any drugs that are
psychotropic drugs I mean ssris are
considered probably the closest thing to
Pure Evil in the world of Scientology
what about weird question what about sex
is there boundaries on what's they're
used to not be it's become very
puritanical in in the last many decades
for a reason I can't actually explain
like miscavige does seem to be
infatuated with controlling sex
like that that is one thing about
miscavige version of Scientology that's
gotten very strange I mean L Ron Hubbard
even specifically voted policy that says
we are no longer going to
regulate in any way the bedroom
activities of people he literally said
from this point on no one is allowed to
be subject to any justice actions of any
kind whatsoever for anything they do in
their sexual lives uh but that was still
did not give uh permission for gay
relationships that was still referring
to straight stuff and uh monogamous only
can you do promise like can you open
marriages and open relationships
according to that over on Hubbard policy
you can yeah but you know I think he
wrote that policy before he created the
C organization and then what happened is
this is actually how this came into
effect uh he created this organization
you had a lot of people on a ship and
everybody was just banging each other
and it created just a nightmare of
personal relationship that it was making
production impossible not because
everybody was spending so much time
banging but because everybody was so
upset about who was begging him yeah I
mean sex and sex and that kind of
dynamic is really um
I mean human humans do what humans do
and then there's drama and all that it's
it's understandable because everybody's
so intimate it's the closed
tribe it makes sense to limit sex
otherwise everyone's but otherwise it
becomes a sex cult yeah which a lot of
them end up becoming well on that topic
would you classify Scientology as a cult
100 but not because I'm like fully
conversant with the academic uh
differentiations between what's a
religion and what's occult I mean
Scientology would say well all small new
religions are Cults and I don't know
that's probably true some people say all
religions are called so maybe like
depends on how you Define religion and
it depends on how you Define cult but I
just fall back on my thing of like if
you're destroying families and
bankrupting your members you're a cult
yeah that that's
US versus them and to them could be your
family it could be your loved ones that
uh
that's deeply destructive and one of the
things you would probably throw into a
definition of a call to something that's
actually destructive because like I do a
lot of stuff that's occult like like Jiu
Jitsu like there's a lot of really
close-knit tribes
but there's no negative toxicity to it
there's no uh divide additional
divisions or if there is it's more
boy
try being a fan of a certain soccer team
and then becoming a fan of another
soccer that's hardcore and like
but I'll tell you I trained Jiu Jitsu as
well and I have found that community of
people to be one of the most loving
and uh helpful
uh group of people ever shout out to
John Keller Gracie Baja Clearwater
um no but seriously like it's one of
it's one of the reasons I continue to do
it despite
my back my hip my shoulder it's like
it's just such a cool group of guys goes
on I used to not I think it was much
more divisive uh in the beginning uh
from this Brazilian Roots one of the
things that's really hard is the team
oriented like
if you're this team you're you're right
or die with this team and there's no
there's a crunches they go to another
team yeah yeah and I think that aspect
that was actually a turn off for me in
the beginning that the toxicity of that
because I understand that a little bit
for the elites
for the highest of the highest that
there's I like the Brotherhood and the
Loyalty of the people like the Olympic
gold medalists the like the best in the
world yes but I feel like recreational
fun like it's like this is all
ultimately about the camaraderie of all
human beings together not some whatever
label you put on your on yourself